hi I'm Christine Brennan we did some
research and we saw that the moon is
drifting away from Earth at one point
four to eight inches per year we were
wondering what would happen if the moon
finally drifts away thanks Chris
Brandon I believe Brendon greetings yes
the moon's moving away from the earth
what happens when the moon eventually
moves away from the earth you should be
a celestial mechanician you should be an
orbital mechanical engineer you should
get a job at Jet Propulsion lab or the
Applied Physics lab that's what you
should do that's what these people do
all day is figure out the orbital
motions of these various bodies so the
moon's moving away so you would presume
its influence on the tide would steadily
decrease and moving away its orbital
period will get slightly longer so the
tides will get slightly more spread out
but when it becomes a significant thing
that's a long time in the future but
it's fun to think about isn't it it's
fun to wonder so keep an eye on things
out there in space and just while we're
here consider joining the Planetary
Society that's what we talk about all
the time is orbital motions how we're
going to get spacecraft to extraordinary
destinations here in the solar system
Mars Europa the moon of Jupiter with
twice as much sea water the earth you
want to set up a telescope on the far
side of the Moon if you want to do that
you're gonna have to understand these
orbital motions big fun Chris Brendan
this stuff is is what makes people go to
schools to learn math so they can
compute orbital motions and understand
the motions of the heavens so go for it